dans bien des régions du pays envoyer
son enfant à la garderie est un luxe qui
n'est pas à la portée de tous la
garderie à toronto nous coûte
actuellement 2350 dollar environ par
mois
juste un autre hypothèque elle coûte
moins cher que la garderie effectivement
marion nguyen aimerait beaucoup avoir un
deuxième enfant mais pays et plus 4000 $
par mois en service de garde est tout
simplement inconcevable
il croit que les coûts actuels freinent
l'accès au marché du travail pour bien
des femmes pour tenter de remédier à la
situation
ottawa annonce un investissement
historique dans un programme national de
garderies
je pense honnêtement que beaucoup de
femmes ne prendrait pas de congés aussi
long si ça ne coûtait pas aussi cher on
est prête à soutenir les gars terry
autour de canada avec beaucoup d'argent
plus précisément ce sont 30 milliards de
dollars qui seront investis sur cinq ans
que le coût d'une place en garderie
baisse à 10 dollars par jour en moyenne
d'ici 2026 plus court terme l'objectif
est de réduire de moitié les frais de
garde à l'extérieur du québec et ce dès
l'an prochain
on a devancé une hyper bonne nouvelle
s'il arrive à le mettre en place dans
les dans les délais impartis
il n'y a pas que les familles torontoise
qui seront soulagés pour les places en
garderie coûte en moyenne 1250 $ par
mois calgary 1165 dollars à vancouver
853 $ à halifax
bien plus que les 180 dollars que les
parents québécois paie actuellement pour
une place en cpe le québec vraiment à
donner une excellent exemple pour le
reste du canada vrai dit cette
expérience a ajouté
entre 1997 et 2000 lui et 70 mille
femmes à la population active
le québec aura quand même droit à sa
part du gâteau 1er christian freewest
concernant les détails du la courbe
bilatérales entre le canada et le québec
on doit parler on doit discuter
l'association québécoise des cpe
souhaite que tout l'argent transféré par
ottawa servent à l'amélioration du
réseau de garderies dans la province
ainsi que phil mills a mis le
gouvernement legault croit pour sa part
qu'ottawa doit lui verser une
compensation financière mais sans
imposer de conditions et ce n'est pas
qu'avec québec que le gouvernement
fédéral devra négocier
quelle sera la petty des autres
provinces de voir ottawa créer un
programme national de garderies
elle qui avait plutôt plaidé pour une
augmentation des transferts en santé
ici l'heure ans arte radio canada ottawa